I HOPE YOU COME BACK AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THE MIDTERMS.
THAT IS OUR STORY FOR TONIGHT.
WE WILL SEE YOU BACK IN NEW YORK
TOMORROW NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
FOR THE PAST 18 MONTHS DEMOCRATS
IN THE CONGRESS AND THEIR P.R.
CONSULTANTS IN THE PRESS HAVE
TOLD YOU THAT DONALD TRUMP WON
THE 2016 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
MOSTLY BECAUSE HIS CAMPAIGN
SOMEHOW COLLUDED WITH THE
GOVERNMENT OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
TO PROVE THAT THEY HAVE BROUGHT
THE USUAL BUSINESS OF GOVERNMENT
HERE IN WASHINGTON BASICALLY TO
A STANDSTILL AND LAUNCHED THE
MOST DIVISIVE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION IN THE HISTORY OF
THE COUNTRY.
IT HAS NOW GONE ON FOR MORE THAN
A YEAR AND YET REMARKABLY TO
THIS VERY DAY WE STILL HAVE NO
PROOF OF COLLUSION.
JUST THIS WEEKEND DEMOCRAT MARK
WARNER OF THE SENATE INTEL
COMMITTEE, SOMEONE EVERYBODY IN
WASHINGTON PRETENDS IS
IMPRESSIVE, WAS OFFERED A CHANCE
ON TELEVISION TO PROVIDE ACTUAL
EVIDENCE OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
HE DECLINED.
OF COURSE HE DID, THEY ALWAYS
DO.
YOU'VE SEEN THIS BEFORE, BUT
TONIGHT WE HAVE SOMETHING
DIFFERENT FOR YOU.
WE HAVE A DEMOCRAT WHO SAYS HE
HAS THE SMOKING GUN.
THREE MONTHS AGO WE MADE THIS
OFFER TO CONGRESSMAN OF
CALIFORNIA, A MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
WATCH.
>> IF YOU HAVE ANY EVIDENCE AT
ALL OF COLLUSION, ANY, AND I
DON'T CARE HOW SMALL IT IS, I
WILL GIVE THE FLOOR TO YOU, AND
I MEAN THAT.
I WANT TO WRAP THIS UP.
I'M SURE YOU DO TOO.
>> Tucker: WE OFFERED THE
CONGRESSMAN A FULL HALF-HOUR
LIVE ON THE SHOW IF YOU COULD
GIVE US EVIDENCE, REAL EVIDENCE
OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION FOR TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN AND TO HIS CREDIT,
TONIGHT HE IS TAKING US UP ON
THAT OFFER.
THERE'S NOTHING STAGED ABOUT
THIS CONVERSATION, THE ONE YOU
ARE ABOUT TO SEE.
IF THE CONGRESSMAN HAS PROVED
THE TRUMP PEOPLE COLLUDED WITH A
FOREIGN POWER WILL BE THE FIRST
TO CALL FOR INDICTMENTS.
BUT IF HE DOESN'T HAVE THAT
PROOF, IF AFTER ALL THIS TIME
THERE IS STILL NO REAL EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION THEN WE WILL KNOW
FOR CERTAIN THAT THIS WHOLE
THING IS A LIE THAT HAS BADLY
DAMAGED OUR COUNTRY.
WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT IN JUST
A MINUTE.
MEANWHILE, THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION CONTINUES TO
EXPOSE DEEP AND TERRIFYING
CORRUPTION IN WASHINGTON, NOT IN
THE WAYS PEOPLE WHO LAUNCHED IT
EXPECTED.
ON FRIDAY, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
AND "WASHINGTON POST" REPORTED
THAT THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
EMPLOYED A SPY WHO POSED AS AN
ADVISOR TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
DURING THE 2016 ELECTION.
HE WAS A LONGTIME CIA ASSET WHO
FED INFORMATION BACK TO FEDERAL
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.
THE OBAMA PEOPLE LIED ABOUT
DOING THIS.
AS FAR AS WE KNOW NOTHING LIKE
THAT HAS EVER HAPPENED IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
RICHARD NIXON WAS ACCUSED OF
LESS THAN THAT AND HE LEFT
OFFICE.
YOU WOULD THINK THE
SELF-DESCRIBED GUARDIANS OF
DEMOCRACY IN THE MEDIA WOULD BE
HORRIFIED BY THE SUGGESTION OF
PARTISAN SPYING NO MATTER WHAT
THEY THINK OF TRUMP PERSONALLY.
BUT THEY ARE NOT HORRIFIED.
INSTEAD THEY ARE AGGRESSIVELY
DEFENDING IT LIKE THE CRATE AND
LACKEYS THEY ARE.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" OVER THE
WEEKEND ACTUALLY RAN AN OP-ED
WITH THIS HEADLINE, WE ARE NOT
MAKING THIS UP.
"THE FBI DIDN'T USE AN INFORMANT
TO GO AFTER TRUMP, THEY USED ONE
TO PROTECT HIM."
AMAZINGLY "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
AGREED WITH THAT.
HERE WAS IT STORY ON THE
SUBJECT.
"FBI USED INFORMANT TO
INVESTIGATE RUSSIA TIES TO
CAMPAIGN, NOT TO SPY."
IN OTHER WORDS, DONALD TRUMP
SHOULD BE GRATEFUL THAT OBAMA'S
SPIES SPYING ON HIM.
IT'S FOR THEIR OWN GOOD.
THE PEOPLE WHO WROTE THIS SHOULD
BE ASHAMED.
IT'S PARTISAN CHEERLEADING AND
EMBARRASSINGLY CREDULOUS.
JUST TRANSCRIBE WHATEVER SPIN
YOU GOT FROM YOUR FBI SOURCE AND
CALL IT A NEW STORY.
HOW WITH THESE IDIOT REPORTERS
FEEL IF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
READ THEIR EMAILS OR TAPPED
THEIR CELL PHONES WERE SENT A
SPY TO SPY ON THEM AND THEN
CLAIMED IT WAS ALL FOR THEIR OWN
GOOD?
OBVIOUSLY THEY WOULD BE OUTRAGED
AND SO WOULD WE, BECAUSE WE ARE
NOT HACKS.
OBAMA'S CIA DIRECTOR JOHN
BRENNAN BY CONTRACT IS A HACK.
HE'S ALSO A LIAR WHO HAS DONE
MORE TO EMBARRASS AND DISCREDIT
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY THAN
ANY OTHER SINGLE PERSON.
BRENNAN HAS BEEN ON TWITTER
ATTACKING TRUMP AND ANYONE ELSE
WHO WANTS TO KNOW MORE THE ABOUT
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION'S
SPYING EFFORTS IN THE LAST
CAMPAIGN AS IF AMERICANS DON'T
HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT WAS SPYING ON THEM
AND WHY.
A RULING CLASS IS COMPLETELY OUT
OF CONTROL, THAT THE REAL LESSON
OF THIS RUSSIAN NONSTATUS.
BYRON YORK FROM THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER" AND
JONATHAN TURLEY.
PROFESSOR, FIRST TO YOU.
DOES THE PUBLIC, DO AMERICANS
HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW IF THEY
WERE SPIED ON AND WHY?
>> I THINK THAT THEY DO.
THESE ARE VERY SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS AND THEY ARE
UNPRECEDENTED.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE TRUTH IS.
MAYBE THERE WAS A VALID REASON
FOR THE INVESTIGATION.
MAYBE THEY USED VALID MEANS, BUT
WE SHOULD WANT TO KNOW.
WHAT I THINK IT IS BEING A CASE
OF WILLFUL BLINDNESS HERE IS
THAT WE HAVE CONFIRMATION THAT
TRUMP APPARENTLY WAS CORRECT
WHEN HE SAID OVER A YEAR AGO
THAT HE HAD PEOPLE IN HIS
CAMPAIGN THAT WERE UNDER
SURVEILLANCE AND IT TURNS OUT
THAT IT WAS MUCH BROADER THAN WE
THOUGHT EVEN THOUGH PEOPLE LIKE
CLAPPER AND OTHER IN THE OBAMA'S
ADMINISTRATION DON'T MAKE IT
ADMINISTRATION TO 90.
IT DOES APPEAR TO BE A
SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM, IT DOES
APPEAR TO BE AN INVESTIGATION
AND NOW YOU HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO REPORTEDLY OFFERED TO BE AN
ADVISOR IN A CAMPAIGN WHEN HE
WAS AN ASSET FOR THE FBI OR THE
CIA OR BOTH.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT JUSTICE
OFFICIAL WOULD SIGN OFF ON THAT.
YOU CAN TRY TO SPLIT THIS AS YOU
MAY.
WHETHER THIS IS AN INVESTIGATION
OR SURVEILLANCE.
BUT FROM A TRUMP STANDPOINT
THERE IS A LEGITIMATE ISSUE.
YOU CAN TELL A VICTIM THIS ISN'T
A MUGGING, IT'S JUST A FORCE
DIVESTITURE BUT IT SURE FEELS
LIKE A MUGGING AND LESS YOU CAN
PROVE TO THE CONTRARY.
>> Tucker: IF BUSH HAD DONE
THIS TO OBAMA I WOULD WANT TO
KNOW WHY AND I THINK IT'S FAIR
TO WANT TO KNOW.
WHEN DID THIS START?
>> THE EMERGENCE OF THIS
INFORMANT HAS KIND OF THROWN
INTO DOUBT OUR PREVIOUS
TIMETABLE OF THIS.
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN TOLD THAT THE
FBI INVESTIGATION FORMALLY
STARTED ON JULY 31ST.
THE ROAD UP SOMETHING CALLED THE
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATION AND
STARTED THIS INVESTIGATION, BUT
NOW WE HEAR THAT THE INFORMANT
WAS ACTUALLY REACHING OUT AND
TALKING TO TRUMP CAMPAIGN PEOPLE
WELL BEFORE THAT, AT LEAST WEEKS
BEFORE THAT, MAYBE LONGER BEFORE
THAT AND I THINK WHAT YOU ARE
SEEING ON CAPITOL HILL IS SOME
INVESTIGATORS, REPUBLICAN
INVESTIGATORS ARE LOOKING EVEN
FURTHER BACK THAN THAT.
>> Tucker: WHAT WOULD THAT
MEAN?
THAT HE WAS DOING IT LATERALLY
BECAUSE HE WAS INTERESTED OR
THAT HE WAS DOING IT AT THE
DIRECTION OF ONE OF THE OBAMA
AGENCIES?
>> THAT HE WAS DOING IT AT THE
DIRECTION OF AN AGENCY BEFORE
THEY HAD A PRETENSE, A PRETEXT
TO ACTUALLY DO THIS.
SO THAT WOULD BE A BIG ISSUE
INSIDE THE FBI.
ALSO, WE ARE SEEING SOME
INVESTIGATORS LOOKING EVEN
FURTHER BACK TO MARCH.
ON MARCH 21ST TRUMP GOES TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," MEETS
WITH THEIR EDITORIAL BOARD.
>> Tucker: I REMEMBER VERY
WELL.
>> A LOT OF CRITICISM FOR NOT
HAVING A FOREIGN POLICY
ADVISORS.
IN PART BECAUSE THE ENTIRE
FOREIGN POLICY ESTABLISHMENT HAD
SHUNNED HIM.
THEY ASK HIM WHO ARE YOUR
ADVISORS?
PEOPLES OF PULLS OUT A PIECE OF
PAPER SAYS HERE THEY ARE.
AND ON THE LIST HE SAYS CARTER
PAGE AND GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS.
WE KNOW NOW THAT JAMES COMEY AND
ANDREW McCABE PERSONALLY
BRIEFED LORETTA LYNCH ABOUT
THEM.
AND THEN SHORTLY THEREAFTER THEY
WERE DISCUSSED AT WHAT IS CALLED
THE NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
PRINCIPALS COMMITTEE, WHICH IS
SECRETARIES OF STATE, TREASURY
AND DEFENSE, CIA, ALL THESE
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT CARTER
PAGE THEN.
>> Tucker: TOTALLY SHOCKING
FOR A PROFESSOR, QUICKLY SINCE
YOU'VE GOT MORE HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS, THEN MOST
PEOPLE, IT IS ANYTHING LIKE THIS
EVER HAPPENED THAT WE KNOW OF?
>> I KNOW OF NO PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVE A CASE TO MAKE.
THE POINT THOUGH IS FOR THOSE
PEOPLE THAT ARE OBJECTING, WHAT
ARE YOU OBJECTING TO?
THIS IS A SERIOUS MATTER.
NO MATTER HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
TRUMP, WE NEED TO FIND OUT THE
TRUTH ABOUT THIS.
IF THERE WAS AN INVESTIGATION,
IF THERE WAS AN ASSET WHO TRIED
TO BECOME AN ADVISOR IN THE
CAMPAIGN, THOSE ARE SERIOUS
MATTERS FOR ALL OF US.
AND I THINK THAT TRUMP IS RIGHT.
HE WON ABOUT IT I THINK IN THE
WRONG WAY, BUT HE HAS A
LEGITIMATE OBJECTION HERE THAT